Young had this idea that people's
shadows reach all the way down to hell,
which is a very frightening concept and
what he meant by that is is that if you
take a look at the impulses that drive
you,
that are actually malevolent,
if you can admit to such impulses that
if you basically follow those all the
way down to their origin,
you find some very nasty things and what
you find down there basically as what
allies you with people who've done
terrible things and that that's not a
very pleasant experience.
I would say.
Although one thing that's worth thinking
about is that it is something that can
protect you against being very,
very badly hurt.
Because one of the things that
characterizes people who develop
posttraumatic stress disorder is that
they're often naive and then they
encounter something that's really not
within their framework of thinking and
it's usually something bad and because
there there isn't anything in their
philosophy,
their way of looking at the world that
has prepared them for that.
They ended up fragmented and devastated
and so it's actually protective to you.
If you can figure out what your.
What your full range of capabilities is
because that can help you understand
other people a lot better and and uh,
to be wiser and more careful in your
actions.
It's also useful,
I think if you want to convince yourself
to act properly because if you regard
yourself as harmless,
which is a big mistake,
then nothing you can do is really that
bad,
right?
Because you're harmless after all.
But if you understand that you're
seriously not harmless,
then that can make you a lot more
careful with yourself.
And I would say that,
that that's especially true.
Maybe when you're dealing,
when you have kids and you start dealing
with your kids.
If you know that what you're capable of
because you're human,
then that can motivate you to be much
more careful with what you say and do.
And I don't mean cautious.
I don't mean timid.
I don't.
I don't mean any of that.
I just mean that you want to keep things
pristine between you and your children,
let's say,
because that way they're on your good
side and you want them on your good side
because children who get on their
parents bad side suffer very badly for
it and sometimes it's because they're
literally abused,
but more often it's because they get
while they get abused,
let's say,
or neglected and much more subtle ways
and you're definitely capable of that.
I mean all you have to do is think about
the way that you've interacted with
someone that you've decided to not like
or maybe someone you genuinely don't
like.
You know,
and that can range from just not paying
any attention to them,
especially if they're doing something
good to really pursuing them and making
their life miserable.
And you can certainly do that with your
family members and you can do that with
your intimate partner.
So you can do that with your friends and
you can do it with yourself.
And so it's really worth knowing that
so.
Well,
the Fox thinks he's royal rule breaker,
but he's really just a two bit thug and
this is where he.
He learns that.
So sorry,
I have a new phone and I'm kind of
stupid with it still so.
Well hypothetically that'll work,
but it probably won't.
Anyways.
The,
the coach ones got these guys in his
grasp now regardless and partly because
they're already down this road and they
can't back off and partly because he
also offers them more money than they've
seen before and so as bad as they are,
they're going to get worse.
Many of you I presume have seen breaking
bad and that's a really good example of
the,
of the incorporation at least in part or
maybe the possession by the shadow from
the Union perspective,
right?
Because you have this ordinary high
school teacher who really thinks that
he's an ax and his family as well.
You know,
like your typical persona.
Roughly speaking,
he's just a normal guy,
but part of the reason that he's a
normal guy is because he actually hasn't
been put in abnormal circumstances and
then all of a sudden he is and he has a
genuine moral conundrum.
Right?
He's going to die of lung cancer and
his.
He has a son who's got a lot of health
problems and he's terrified that that
he's going to leave his wife and his
child behind with nothing and then of
course as the story and so he decides to
do something that temporarily that he
regards as what they would normally
regard as reprehensible.
And of course he just gets tangled up in
that.
But then as the story unfolds,
you see that there's.
It's more complicated because it's not
that he was just innocent,
good guy and he decided to turn bad.
He's also very resentful and angry and
it's partly because he's a bit of a
pushover at the beginning or maybe more
than a bit of a pushover,
and also that he didn't really fulfill
his own potential and that,
you know,
he,
he had friends who walked down the
entrepreneurial path and maybe they
weren't quite fair to him,
but whatever,
he ends up not very successful as a high
school teacher.
So he's really angry about that.
And so there's more motivation for him
opening up the door to the terrible
elements of his personality than just
the fact that he's got good motivations
to do so and that,
that unfolds,
you know,
and so you see that warps and twists and
is resentful.
Character increasingly manifest
themselves as he walks down this road to
really total brutality.
And it,
it's,
it's quite good.
Um,
there's a book called ordinary men
that's a lot like that.
I don't think I've mentioned that to you
before,
but ordinary men is a book about.
It's the best book of it's type.
Maybe it's the only book of its type.
It's possible,
but it's plotted,
much like breaking bad in some sense.
It's a story about these German
policemen in early stages of World War
II and they were guys who were old
enough to be raised in Germany really
before the hitlarian propaganda came out
in full force,
you know,
if you were a teenager,
say in the 1930,
so you are going to be pulled right into
the propaganda machine and maybe you
were part of the Hitler youth and like
you were raised in that,
you know,
but if you were older than you were
raised before that and you're not as
amenable to propaganda once you're older
than about.
While I would say about 22 or something
like that.
It's,
it's pretty young actually.
If you're gonna make a soldier,
you have to get a soldier young because
once people are in their early twenties,
say they're kind of.
They already have their personality
developed.
Anyways.
These policemen were sent into Poland
after the Germans marched through and
uh,
you know,
it was wartime and there is this
hypothesis in Germany that the Jews in
particular,
we're operating as a fifth column and
undermining the German war effort
because of course the Germans blamed the
Jews and a variety of other people for
actually setting up the conditions that
made the war necessary.
And so when the police were sent into
Poland,
they were also required to make peace
roughly speaking.
And so they started up by.
They started out by rounding up all the
Jewish men between 18 and 65 and
gathering them in,
in stadiums and then shipping them off
on the trains.
But that isn't where they ended.
They ended in a very,
very dark place.
I mean,
these guys were going out in the field
with naked pregnant women and shooting
them in the back of the head by the end
of their training.
And what's really interesting about that
is that is that their commander told him
that they could go home at any time.
So this is,
this is not one of those examples of
people following orders.
And the reason they didn't,
roughly speaking,
there's many reasons,
but one of the reasons they didn't is
because they didn't think it was
comradely,
so to speak,
to leave their,
the guys they were working with to do
all the dirty work and run off now.
And that's really,
that's really an interesting fact,
you know,
because you'd in,
in different circumstances,
you wouldn't think about that as
reprehensible,
right?
You'd think,
well that's part of teamwork and on your
rough circumstances.
And that's at least in part how they
viewed it.
And they were also made physically ill
multiple times physically and
psychologically ill by the things that
they had to do.
But they kept doing them anyways.
So it's one step at a time.
And that's the thing is that you end up
in very bad places one step at a time.
So you've gotta watch those steps.